dans sa boule c'est un dyke alexis c'est
vraiment intéressant ça valait le coup
de deux ont discuté de choses de ce
professionnel the storm avec mika
bonjour mes cadeaux si mika change et de
micros c'est un bon jour écouter
aujourd'hui on se trouve sur heroes nos
deux formes c'est l'un des seuls mots
bas auquel je joue parce que c'est basé
sur l'univers de blizzard est un univers
que qu'on apprécie on peut le dire mais
qu'est ce qu'elle perçoit on va jouer
pendant cette guerre manouche louga
chogal exactement en fait jeu égal c'est
un seul et unique perso mais deux
joueurs le jour en même temps moi en
gros je vais gérer les déplacements et
mika va gérer les sorts à distance et
moi c'est l'essor au corps à corps alors
en face de nous c'est une équipe de
quatre personnes mais nous on est 2 fois
2 quand même ouais mais cannes c'est
mieux de fin de non non non il faut
croire nous croyons nous s'il vous plaît
et je me gratte les celle dont je vous
parlais un problème donc mikala en fait
on est sur le même perso lui et moi sauf
que lui peut pas bouger c'est moi qui
gère les déplacements alors dans ce mode
de jeu en gros le soir il se met à faire
nuit ce qui est plutôt logique et il ya
deux gros boss qui apparaissent faut les
buts et amassé des plans très au bout de
100 plants ramasser ça crée un boss chez
nous dont on peut prendre le contrôle
ces prêts étaient prêtes est prête et
prêts à huy ne pouviez tout seul tpr
être dans mon
suppression à la fois que moi pourquoi
la poule a où la boule est ce que tu es
prêt mécano fait du bruit dans la salle
la boule lequel vous voyez le poste
vient d'apparaître parce qu'il fait nuit
il ya des petites plantes avec mesa ccpo
attendez attendez il ya embrouilles en
gros une patate de pour un basique
défonce lui la défonce celui-là la boule
au mad'art il s'en sort avec très peu
d'acheter en fait pour expliquer la
boulette
moi je lance la boulimie cas il appuie
sur une touche pour la faire exploser ce
qui est très compliqué j'ai lancé la
boule ouais c'est cool gb lancé sarah
reid
ils ont besoin d'être ici donc on va y
aller tu es prête est prête et après on
se fait lui de la poule la boule non on
est des glands pls au caire où tout le
monde il va se battant les heat sous la
semelle invisible
va t on se fait le boss partis non non
non non non il ya médailles et on s'en
fout on va défoncer vas-y viens on
t'attend
ici on n'avait pas car tu m'as donné
cette force est la faille c'est la
faillite
ça joue rapidement gelé plus assis gelé
attention cela ait pu arriver
c'est génial la foule regardez regardez
regardez là j'ai fait le point le plus
délicat de la moutte c'est la boule en
voilà au tulle a touché et tu tires ou
tu pointes et pour sa défense le mica
par les boules mais non j'ai fait de la
merde
on rire des cadeaux enfin les boules
retourne retrouve 0,36 et le couple
royal gobelins ya les copains des
gobelins je te fais on se fait on se
fait on se fait les kamikazes médias
c'est la boule c'est la boule c'est la
boule c'est la boule c'est la boule que
je préfère c'est la foule celle là alors
on retourne au mit de taper à ce modèle
qui est un gars de diablo ça que j'aime
bien c'est que tu croises vraiment des
gens des différents jeux kouao aux
opérations en contrats aidés mayday
mayday mayday mayday jeu tant que
j'attends que je tombe
j'essaie de le câble au fil du temps
apparu fiable il nous a mis dans la
merde on est dans la merde dans le cocon
on va le maire jean ya des gars on veut
des pousses voyez la pousse là elle va
apparaitre ici litigieux mais voilà
pardon je voterai un truc au chaud c'est
+30 points bouger prolé non non on prend
les plantes comprendre les planteurs
indépendants allait prendre va les
prendre va dépendre des grandes épreuves
les premiers projets et lui foule il
fallait prendre fait pas que les moules
tu les prends mais tu te tais [ __ ] si
les pros et vas-y putsch j'ai lancé la
boule thiaw laye
alors regardez l'aïe a largué notre
équipe qui a pris la note plantes et ya
un gars de leur équipe qui a pris leur
planche et qui est en train de fêter la
balle border les pas beaux à nice titien
combats opposent aux ltte et on les
domine en vrai allez on va se faire la
plante et ouais allez allez lui il est
mort il est mort on va se mettre là s'il
va se mettre invisible on va prévoir
voilà et eau pour ta cagoule noire fait
chaud
non merde non olala iso tout cas ils
nous ont des coûts a si bien c'est
qu'ils ont fait quatorze qu'il en a fait
quatre huawei ouais ouais ouais ouais je
le regardais le regarder les rochers aux
larmes et ouais mais tu sais pourquoi
j'ai perdu parce que je voulais voir les
petits dragons voilà hockey deuxième
game on a choisi de perçoit ces drones
le boucher de diablo et le balafré de
warcraft est en fait chacun une
particularité lui il peut attirer des
aînés qui sont super loin avec son
crochet et moi je peux chercher un mec à
travers la map un plaisir c'est parti
vicat a du coup on est contre à boucher
comme moi alors le boucher il a un
passif il ramasse du sang sur les
ennemis et ça augmente ses dégâts vous
voyez alors dans ce mode de jeu s'il ya
des piliers qui s'activent et il faut
tuer 20 monstre pour avoir un gros boss
qui ce poney qui défonce les ennemis le
pilier là ça nous rappelle diablos et
moi le pilier aux eaux
moi j'ai un pilier dans mon cas sont les
regardons ça fait quelques annonces a
fait mouche mais non on est couché
depuis le matin allez tu as envie de
l'émotion vite les mots on est bien en
début d'année viande et bien et c'est
bon on a réussi et regarde un monstre
qui nous vient tout droit de demeurer
nous aider ce monster et du coup ils
allaient pouvoir aléatoire comme youtube
holla holla holla travail de fond moi je
suis grand show grand show pour un show
peu comme ça à bata elle met un terme à
la toile talent dans ta tête je sens
qu'en face ils voient arriver ils
voulaient voler là est la réponse dans
une seconde ils sont ce qu'ils sont hier
les visites regarde le con ça va être
chaud on focus le boucher ouais ok c'est
parti
bush et le foot non plus convaincu
contre castrés voilà et voilà on a perdu
on a perdu on s'est fait avoir attendu
si toi aussi il ne les laisse pas
s'enfuir et on va peut-être gagner une
game ou bien peut-être
ok ok je monte mon merveilleux il en
reste quand les mecs un mot tu es sans
un hoquet gimont utile à vous allez voir
on va rôtir des gens ça s'appelle
rôtisserie cc davos brutalité on
s'appelle on l'a fait et voilà et le
stuff et ce qui est bien c'est que quand
on détruit un peu la base année ça nous
donne des leaks les avoir combattus et
hop là puisque sur xp généraux qui suit
vous avoir ouvert aux tirs des gens dans
trois toits bout alors j'espère qu'un
canal d'amenée viennent des panneaux par
le haut par les eaux par l'eau attention
dans les vins c'est bon mais courir ses
parts à bréhat les aspérités du coup les
à split et c'était grave howarth
mais les dégâts qu'elle fait elle mec
ouais ouais ça va passer ça olala cette
fois çi rien compris on a gagné
j'ai pas mal à gagner oh là là
incroyable quelle fight hors du commun
on a eu dominateur on est bien elle est
mort ce jeudi elle voilà échec échec de
mou indien qui lui reste à faire chier
avec ça je fais tout ça on chope le mob
et on gagne cette [ __ ] de game wuala
ça me rappelle quand on a fallu swt
matches sur la scène on l'a jamais fait
tu la vois tu la vois kerrigan est bas
on la compotée et battant les voies pour
la tenue la boue le respect se perd
vient pas là là là là oh [ __ ] hausse
mais combien sarah super 7e michael
chang xian et non mais là l'ami casser
ces boues takaji la charge dans saxo 24
secondes 3 go 2 go
non il ne lâche plus
et ça c'est fait c'est moi je crois que
c'est fini un regard des écrans plats ou
salés tue pas voilà je voulais voir les
objets légendaires c'est pour ça que
j'ai fait exprès de gagner et moi je
soutiens poutine au surcroît d'offre de
stores j'espère que ça vous a plu c'est
le cas n'hésitez pas mal d'eau comme
d'habitude mais qu'at on ré sur un ratio
positif une défaite une victoire c'est
vraiment que du coup ses notes c'est
positif
du coup quoi c'est neutre c'est 1 1
c'est positif
non si ça fait 1 mais du coup c'est zéro
non mais c'est c1 mais maintenant notre
ratio et1 notre résultat positif
ça fait 1 + 1 / 2 1 c'est pour moi mais
du coup ce n'est pas positif ça c'est
négatif en dessous de 1 au dessus de
1,10 u21 c'est positif
tu vas permettant des bouts de la chaîne
de mecha n'hésitez pas soyez nombreux
on va aller ont sauté dans une prochaine
vidéo et que tu m'a fait plaisir de vous
présenter ce petit mot bas que j'aime
bien parce que moi je me détends dessus
il ya un objectif à faire en plus à
chaque fois donc je suis univers est
sympa voilà le petit univers blizzard
nous fait plaisir comme à chaque fois à
la centrer vers de projet vidéo merci
d'avoir regardé portez vous bien tu as
deux bombes